Wow it's the most surreal feeling ever
and I think the most amazing thing about
me being spider-man right now is that I
didn't get this job on my own my family
were as involved as I was my agents of
course and loads of people that I worked
with especially Jon Bernthal who's now
the Punisher who's killing it so it's
nice to be able to share this experience
with the people that are kind of closer
to closest to me in my life which is
crazy because it's been such a big
secret well it was kind of not a secret
but was a secret and it's it's been
super difficult to not be telling people
what the film is about and stuff so it's
now really nice that people can see
Civil War and and enjoy it's a dream
come true I mean I really couldn't have
asked for a better way to be introduced
and the Russo brothers did it so
perfectly and yeah so I'm just delighted
I think you are going to get to see a
sides of Peter Parker we've never seen
before
obviously I'm far younger but we're
going to get to see a kid who's trying
to do his algebra homework but also try
and make New York a safer place so it's
a really fun balance between the two as
a kid
I dressed up as spider-man probably
every day for about a year so playing
this character was kind of a dream come
true for me and also to play a character
like this amongst such a fantastic cast
is also such an honor you know and and
to be given this privilege by Marvel and
Sony in the Russos I just I couldn't be
more grateful and I just want to do
everything I can in my power to make the
best movies possible you know it was
definitely very daunting to start off
with I mean my first day on set I was
being walked through the set with her
with a runner and he walked me into this
green room to all of the Avengers and
all of their getup and stuff so
was it was pretty terrifying but there
was so nice and so down-to-earth and I'd
met Robert before and Chris before so
they sort of welcomed me and introduced
me to the rest of the cast so I was I
was I was in good hands right away I am
on Team Iron Man and why I cannot tell
you you have to wait to see the movie
you